[Música]
Bienvenidos a directo cop 27 el programa
en el que les traemos las noticias más
relevantes de la Cumbre climática en
Egipto y Pese que hoy mucha de la
atención mediática se la llevó la
presencia del presidente de Estados
Unidos joeyden en la cop27 y su reunión
con el presidente de Egipto las
negociaciones climáticas de este viernes
se centraron en el tema de la
descarbonización es decir cómo hacer que
la humanidad vaya dejando de lado los
combustibles fósiles sin embargo los
datos revelan que este consume este
consumo sigue aumentando ampliamos con
nuestra enviada especial a charmel Shake
Marina Colorado
Sí es que dejar de quemar carbón
petróleo y gas es la manera más
importante o la medida más importante
para frenar el calentamiento global y
frenar el cambio climático sin embargo
la tendencia no parece ser esta un
informe publicado hoy en la cop27
anuncia que seguramente las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero aumentarán
en un 1% en 2022 Esto hace que superemos
los niveles de 2019 recordemos que
durante la pandemia de Kobe 19 si hubo
un descenso de estas emisiones pero solo
temporal este aumento hace que haya un
50% de posibilidades de que alcancemos o
superemos el grado y medio centígrado de
calentamiento una temperatura límite
acordada durante la Cope en París para
prevenir el calentamiento global bueno
para prevenir los peores efectos del
calentamiento global Pues esta este
aumento de 1% hace que tengamos un 50%
de probabilidades de alcanzarlo en los
próximos nueve años y no para el 2100
como estaba previsto en el acuerdo de
París para analizar toda esta
información me acompaña Catalina gonda
ella es coordinadora de políticas
climáticas y en la fundación ambiente y
recursos naturales Muchísimas gracias
por estar en France 24 como vemos este
informe
bueno contradice lo que los científicos
nos advierten que tenemos que estar
reduciendo un 5% anualmente las
emisiones para lograr frenar el
calentamiento global Cómo Cómo cuáles tu
análisis acerca de este informe bueno Es
bastante preocupante el informe porque
demuestra que no estamos en una
trayectoria compatible con limitar el
aumento de la temperatura media global
este a 1,5 grados centígrados y
justamente es un fiel reflejo de la
inacción que se está dando en materia
energética como sabemos tenemos que
empezar a transicionar de manera muy
acelerada hacia un sistema energético
limpio en carbono este descentralizado
entonces bueno justamente es preocupante
justamente en el marco de una Cup en la
que el lema es implementación y también
en un contexto de impactos climáticos
cada vez más severos entonces realmente
es preocupante este este reporte los
resultados que indica este reporte en el
marco de estas conversaciones y bueno
justamente da una señal para que se
trate de realmente poner sobre la mesa
ofertas y compromisos mucho más
ambiciosos y pasar de una vez hacia
implementar esos compromisos
Precisamente en esta cop cuyo objetivo
es descarbonizar la economía y alejarnos
de los combustibles fósiles ahí más de
630 representantes o personas con
estrechos vínculos con compañías
petroleras Qué mensaje lanza Esto bueno
para ponerlo en referencia
esta delegación de lo vistas de la
industria fósil es mucho mayor que las
delegaciones de los 10 países más
vulnerables a los impactos del cambio
climático Así que digamos es muy
preocupante que sea permitida digamos
esta participación de alguna manera
porque son personas que de alguna manera
vienen a digamos boicotear este tipo de
Progreso en Estos espacios y digamos
justamente atrasar cualquier
transformación en materia energética
entonces me parece que es algo
importante de visibilizar de de digamos
de tratar de evitar Incluso en las
próximas instancias porque bueno es
atenta directamente contra este la
integridad planetaria Así que es
importante también este tener en cuenta
de que estos procesos no están solamente
digamos no no no convoca nada más a
países y a delegaciones de sociedad
civil sino también Bueno a industrias
muy contaminantes y finalmente mirando
un poquito hacia el futuro en diciembre
se celebra la cop 15 la Cup de la
biodiversidad de una Cumbre climática
menos conocida que estas de cambio
climático Pero igualmente importante
Cuál es la relación entre biodiversidad
y frenar el calentamiento global y el
cambio climático bueno la crisis
climática y la crisis de pérdida de
biodiversidad están completamente
vinculadas de hecho Se podría decir que
son dos síntomas de un mismo problema
una crisis si de nuestra manera de este
de crecer económicamente Si se quiere
digamos este también debatir ese
concepto de crecimiento económico
ilimitado así que bueno tienen una un
vínculo sumamente estrecho y de hecho si
no se Avanza en materia climática la
biodiversidad enfrenta sirios riesgos en
las próximas décadas y además es
fundamental poder abordar la pérdida de
biodiversidad porque justamente es lo
que da sustento a muchos de los
ecosistemas que representan los mayores
reservorios de carbono Entonces es
fundamental que estas dos crisis sean
atacadas de manera integrada y de
paralela Así que es clave que la Cup de
biodiversidad ahora en diciembre de un
resultado muy ambicioso en materia de
poder para poder justamente abordar esta
crisis pues con este mensaje para poder
abordar precisamente la crisis climática
como bien decía Catalina Muchísimas
gracias por estar esperando 24 nos
despedimos en este directo con 27
a nuestras enviadas especiales en la cop
27 Les agradecemos a muchos sus reportes
y a ustedes Muchas gracias por su
atención sigan con nosotros
[Música]